the united states is battling the
largest measles outbreak in decades
the rapid spread of measles is prompting
newer and stronger measures from health
officials across the country
the latest outbreaks are highlighting
pockets of unvaccinated people
communities across the country are
taking drastic measures
amid the backdrop of the current
outbreak if you go online you might see
false information about vaccines
information that science is debunked for
years like this the spread of
misinformation can affect something like
a measles outbreak or you know attitudes
about information in general of course
because it's affecting the way that
people are getting their information
it's affecting what they believe so far
there are no large-scale studies that
say that vaccine misinformation causes
outbreaks but social media companies are
starting to make changes to their core
products in an effort to tamp down on
these kinds of posts changes that some
critics say aren't enough here's a look
at what they're doing some are making it
harder for users to search for false
content Facebook Instagram and Pinterest
are relying on information from global
health organizations to help them
identify false information and make it
harder to find for example
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention has confirmed that there's no
link between getting the measles vaccine
and developing autism Facebook takes
this kind of information and uses a
combination of Technology and human
reviewers to identify groups that
suggest that there is a link once a page
gets flagged Facebook's algorithm makes
it harder to find
for example they would likely flag we
know vaccines cause autism 1 2 3 a group
we made up for the purpose of this video
once flagged the page would appear lower
in the newsfeed it would also be reduced
in search results and removed from
search recommendations for Facebook the
system is only in place for pages that
make explicitly false claims as in
claims that are proven to be
scientifically incorrect that means many
groups that use anti vaccine language
but don't include a specifically false
claim might not get flagged this made-up
group for example might not get flagged
even though it's promoting anti vaccine
opinions
you'll get is a short-term fix for again
probably those things that have gained
the most publicity but that doesn't mean
that there's that that there is
something fundamentally changed about
the way that the platform is operating
or in many cases the kind of content
that you can find in response Facebook
cites research that complements previous
findings that shows how the overall
consumption of false news on Facebook
has declined since the 2016 u.s.
elections other platforms like Instagram
and Pinterest have made moves to stop
spreading misinformation by hiding
results for false hashtags now when you
search for hashtag vaccines cause autism
on Instagram or hashtag vaccines cause
SIDS on Pinterest nothing pops up but
similar to Facebook opinion hashtags
won't be banned on Instagram so if you
search for hashtag vaccines are bad
searches will still come up and even
some hashtags that are false like
hashtag vaccines cause autism read the
studies still pop up Instagram says it's
constantly trying to get ahead of
permutations of the hashtag and
vernacular that they think still
infringes upon their misinformation
policies they say they view their
efforts to combat misinformation more
broadly saying they're not problems you
can fix but rather issues you can
continually improve on the tools that
can operate at the scale that these
platforms need do not have the
sophistication and the nuance to be able
to distinguish between something that is
you know definitely misinformation and
something that definitely isn't and so
what you tend to get in these solutions
are these kind of these kind of
whack-a-mole approaches right where one
set of search results will be black
blocked or ones hashtag will be blocked
because that's been flagged as
problematic YouTube is also trying to
counteract misinformation by giving
users information from third-party
sources like Wikipedia and Encyclopedia
Britannica the aim is to guide users to
more sources where they can fact check
information for themselves for example
look at this trailer for a documentary
that claims to educate parents around
the world about what it calls vaccine
injury just below the video there's a
link to the Wikipedia page for vaccine
controversies the first sentence of the
page explains how the world health
organization identified vaccine
hesitancy as one of the top 10 global
threats of 2019 whatsapp is also working
to fight against the spread of
misinformation by changing its rules on
forwarding in India anti vaccine
misinformation is spreading on the
messaging service making it harder to
root out measles and rubella in a
country where tens of thousands of
people are struck by the disease's every
year and the story is one of the biggest
examples of how spreading fake news
could lead to massive social and
political problems users are sending
around messages like this one that says
in Hindi and urdu don't use vaccinations
save the lives of your children whatsapp
has recently made product changes to
fight against misinformation of all
kinds not just related to health
belike Kavya shed joy not rumors before
whatsapp users could forward a message
to over a hundred accounts at the same
time but as of January 2019 whatsapp
tweaked its rules we're now you can only
forward a message to up to five chats
globally are you really sure that this
is true no man it was a followed they've
also started marking which messages had
been forwarded by a user rather than
sent directly for example this message
with the forwarded tag comes from a
third party the messaging service also
allows users to report accounts by
clicking here if whatsapp's automated
system recognizes that an account has
been reported many times they may ban it
whatsapp says it bans nearly two million
accounts per month but while the company
bans accounts that many users have
reported they don't ban accounts based
on reports about the content of messages
so the account that sent the message
from before won't necessarily be banned
so as these companies introduce new
rules to fight against the spread of
vaccine misinformation there's one
common theme none of them offer a
blanket solution owning it means one
taking responsibility for the editorial
choices that they are making and where
they fall short and also maybe
acknowledging that if they're that if
their tools can't keep up with the
volume of information flowing across the
platform maybe that much information
shouldn't be flowing across the platform
in response Pinterest has said that much
of their content comes onto their site
from other platforms that don't have a
pall
we'll see against health misinformation
which is why this is an industry-wide
issue that will only improve if more
companies recognize the effectiveness of
vaccines like measles mumps and rubella
as settled science YouTube says their
changes are still taking effect but a
very preliminary look shows that it is
limiting the spread of borderline
content and harmful misinformation on
their platform and whatsapp has made it
clear when users have received forwarded
information and limited for words to
reduce the spread of viral content all
of the company's mentions say they're
working on longer-term fixes to solve
the problem
Facebook is planning to add warning
signs on pages and groups that are known
to spread false information so this
made-up group would likely have a symbol
or warning sign pop up beside the page
as these companies continue to employ
these rules to fight against health
misinformation the measles outbreak
continues to grow